notre équipe est prête à tout pour
protéger la belle n'a rien à voir avec
des sauvetages en mer
cb watch fillette début du stage demain
à 06 00 arrête de dire 06 00 c'est pas
la vraie heures on sait tous ce cas là
je n'ai pas touché mais c'est un meurtre
de quelqu'un veut brouiller les pistes
on est sauveteur patrick à la voix
comprends pas ce que ça veut dire mais
pourquoi on dirait un courrier depuis la
petite emma le 21 juin
notre équipe c'est l'élite de l'élite si
vous avez envie moi les îles autre fois
peut-être
[Musique]
drogue meurtre tout a commencé quand
lille a pris les rênes pourquoi tu veux
jouer les héros parce que tu es ab watch
on va faire un repérage discret concours
ce plan dans une morgue tient tranquille
coup de cieux c'est juste du grade ma
came
bewan ch alerte à malibu bienvenue la
paix oit
notre équipe c'est l'élite de l'élite
nous sommes l'âme de cette plage
olympique
témoin des faits qu un peu plus gros et
dégage comme à poutres apparentes ça
marche une grande poutre et nord
les petites sirènes qui vient passer les
sélections pas besoin sheen matt brody
j'ai deux médailles d'or la prod him and
broad il bien sûr sauf que nous on
s'emballe et qu'est ce que tu fais là tu
mates messages de fans ici
ici on va intégrer cette équipe one
direction faut le mériter
affectés sur sept et transport de fret
ont quitté une bête king kong
mais moi je suis rapide drogue meurtre
la cadavre sur notre plage tout a
commencé quand elle est un objet bien
repérer votre petit jeune on va devoir
faire ce que des watts fr 2000
vous êtes maître nageur va policiers
[Musique]
pourquoi on a toujours l'impression
qu'elles courent au ralenti cette fille
est la preuve que tu existes faut y
aller incognito un os qu il est passé
brody
pourquoi tu t'es maquiller comment ça
pourquoi je suis maquillée c'est un peu
chargé je suis canon super bonne 13 je
suis un tsunami fils de
[Musique]
le bourny peut aller se rhabiller en
france
pourquoi on est venu à la morgue pour
chercher les preuves j'ai quelqu'un qui
vient qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors fausse
cacher tout ça je suis couché sur une
vieille dame morte pourquoi tu après ce
tiroir nuit sont vides il ya un truc
cool dessus c'est juste du grade cadavre
de la grèce portent vite par la nécrose
des pâtes à chaque c'est bon là je me
casse